hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast medical cannabis a
pharmacist journey from skeptic to
advocate presented by hall neighbor
pharmacist medical cannabis research
Australia I am Christina Mahalo
collaborate and I'll be your moderator
for today's events we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots lab roots is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen will answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional ward at the bottom center of
your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and those offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming Paul
May or I will now turn the presentation
over to him hello thank you so today I
want to talk about my journey from
cannabis skeptic to an advocate and I've
been a pharmacist for 30 years and over
that time I've never seen cannabis as
medicine I'll cure lease in it as a
recreational drug and over the last few
years I've come a full circle and have
been starting out I've been traveling
the world I've been speaking to lots of
scientists about this and I've been to
the US Canada and is well visiting
growing facilities visiting laboratories
and it's a really fascinating area that
I see of rediscovered medicine and it
helps patients that have no other
treatment options in some cases it has a
big future in medicine and one of their
first trips away we actually visited the
cannabis science conference and I really
do think the first time I'd be going to
the u.s. I'd be taking my kids to
Disneyland instead I found myself at
canvas boot camp and it was a fantastic
event I did expect everyone to be there
to have dreadlocks and be wearing
tie-dye and I was quite pleasantly
surprised there was a lot of scientists
there and they're doing some amazing
things we did some cannabis so first up
big disclaimer I'm not a cannabis user
I've never used it medically spiritually
recreationally or otherwise my poison of
choice is beer I love beer it gives me
flawless dance moves and makes my jokes
funnier and this picture here is one of
our first trips to the US where we went
to Portland OR Portland as I like to
call it and we went on a cycling brewery
tour was a really fun day we got to
sample a lot of craft brews and the very
same company who did this Southie
brewery tour also offered a cycling
cannabis tour with a visit of three
cannabis dispensaries and gave all
participants a joint an edible at the
end we didn't do that true but it looked
kind of fun and a lot of the harm
statistics I'm going to be present to
you presented shortly compare alcohol
this is cannabis canvas doesn't really
barely know them going to get up at all
in time soon so in my education ethical
professional in cannabis was along the
lines of pharmacy students wherever at a
party and someone lit up a joint were to
leave their party immediately and no one
ever did it became kind of a running
joke but you first forward to modern day
one
my current pharmacist her education in
cannabis was presented in half now
format by a policeman which covered all
illicit drugs which I don't see is
really scientific and it's kind of like
a nun giving you a class in sex
education so we're hoping to change some
of that today you'll laugh at this but
my first introduction to medicinal
cannabis what really sparked my interest
was the most unscientific of journals
Facebook I came across it is a Maine
which quoted actual death statistics
from the US third year 2012 and I was
quite shocked to the results rather very
top you've got cancer sticks and sitting
on couches the usual suspects are
responsible for a lot of people dying
Ishi yes underneath that my favorite
beer which has got quite a big toll but
the one that really surprised me was
prescription drugs largely
pharmaceutical opioids which are
responsible for over 30,000 deaths each
year in the US and I see these is
preventable guilty it's a massive toll
and I'm told that that was in year 2012
in 2017 it was close to 50,000 sodas in
the true sense of word and epidemic now
this name showed cannabis right down the
very bottom on zero and I thought no way
and not be true how can a drug that is
that dangerous that pharmacist have to
leave parties because of leave that safe
and it turns out cannabis is very
difficult to overdose on you have to eat
something like a ton of the stuff to
overdose on I don't quite believe the
figures des rois some poor person out
there somewhere may be allergic to
cannabis but it is very difficult to
overdose on and you have to have very
large volume and to overdose on this
very few if even though we call the
deaths involving medicinal cannabis and
that doesn't mean all cannabis users
safe all the time so to prove a point we
called some Australian data also from
the year 2012 the very trouble this line
so which was spots or a big time not
shopping read the numbers here but
underneath that they were in the year
2012 577 people died in Australia from
overdosing on pharmaceutical opioids and
right down the very bottom on zero was
cannabis so there's a bit of a trend
forming here in terms of the cute little
toxicity how this chart works the figure
on the Left which is always one is the
amount of a drug required to give
effective dose the figure on the right
is how many of those choices it takes to
kill you
Rhonda very trophy is heroin on one
tooth teeth which is the most dangerous
and alcohol sitting on one to ten in
practical terms for beers might get you
drunk 40 beers might kill you further
down we've got caffeine one two fifty
and write down the very bottom we've got
cannabis on one two greater than 20,000
so one joint might get you high
over 20,000 joints would overdose you so
if you could afford 20,000 genes and you
may come close to overdosing on campus
now I always thought cannabis was highly
addictive it turns out it's a lot lower
on the scale than I thought the most
addictive substance on this scale anyway
is heroin closely followed by its cousin
methadone further down we've got alcohol
and nicotine they're both quite
addictive substances and right down on
the right hand side a is cannabis
cannabis it's on 0.8 on the addiction
scale caffeine is not on this scale but
if it was on here be 0.9 so in practical
trans cannabis is less addictive than
coffee
very surprising chemist was widely sold
in pharmacies circa 1930s it was widely
used for some of the same things were
rediscovering now like chronic pain he
was used for childhood epilepsy and was
used for cancer pain patients and I've
seen some of these bottles sitting in in
old shell
and I didn't think much of the time but
a lot of these names I did a bit of
research on them they were
pharmaceutical companies that I remember
when I first started in pharmacy and a
lot of them have evolved and merge and a
growing since then and I I pulled up the
times and they're now a big
pharmaceutical companies that made their
start still in cannabis they no longer
sell cannabis but they might well one
day in the near future what happened now
in 1934 the u.s. legalized alcohol that
meant there was a big government
Parliament sitting around doing nothing
and previously they said there was not a
problem with cannabis use it did not
cause harm in society but once they feel
themselves unemployed it was a different
story and they went after cannabis
largely on the basis of an unscientific
movie called reefer madness and
proclaimed that cannabis users were
violent and sex-crazed at the time the
American Medical Association spoke out
against them that said no we actually
use it as a medicine
it's got valid medical uses and there's
a lot of things we're researching is
useful but they're overruled and
cannabis was banned many other countries
around the world followed suit
1:42 chemist was removed from the US
pharmacopoeia now the canvas plan itself
is quite complex there's over 50
different ingredients and they include
waxes to name the cannabinoids and cells
and chlorophylls
there's too many ingredients in
pharmaceutical terms THC which is the
bit that is a psychoactive potentially
and CBD which is non psychoactive and
it's got a lot of medical uses and most
pharmaceutical products will contain an
issue of these two ingredients there's
also a bunch of another collab annoys
many which are still being investigated
they haven't enough to be studied for
last 80 years because a product
prohibition that scientists are slowly
unlocking some of the mysteries the
intra cannabinoid system I'd never heard
of and it turns out our body has a
homeostatic system called the
endocannabinoid system which is only
deciding to be taught in medical schools
now what's that's covered in the
mid-nineteenth and there's two
cannabinoid receptors cb1 and cb2 CB
ones mainly found in the brain and CB 2
is found in vital organs and the skin
now our body produces natural
cannabinoid chemicals and noun to mine
and to AG and they work on receptors and
they can enter a cannabinoid system and
control such things as appetite the
immune system and pain which explains a
lot about what cannabis does because the
cannabis and chemicals mimics these
natural injury cannabinoid so unlike
opioids there's no cannabinoid receptors
in the part of the brain or the brain
stem which regulates the heart rate and
breathing so it's much safer to keep
large doses especially in palliative
care where you might need to increase
the dose depending on how the patients
are coping and what how how bad you need
to to treat certain conditions now if
you look at cannabis science you come
across this term the entourage effect
which is only a theory that not one
ingredient works in one receptor at one
time it's theorized that two or more
cannabinoids work on in conjunction on
one or more receptors at the same time
now in medical terms
there was a great article published in
January 2017 by the National Academies
of science engineering and medicine
they're supposedly the world's biggest
body of skeptics there's a lot of Harper
trained professors we looked at what
cannabis can and can't do and they
looked at every bit of research ever
done on cannabis and scaled from the
anecdotal evidence that was biased
high-quality evidence which in gold
standard clinical trials with see bones
etc and they came to the conclusion
there were three areas where there was
good clinical evidence of medical
cannabis was of benefit the biggest one
being chronic pain which accounts for
about 70% of people using medicinal
cannabis
not only does medical cannabis help the
pain of patients
it also has quite a few other benefits
in areas such as anti-anxiety it helps
with insomnia it's helped spasm help us
also in nausea so rather than a session
being a gateway drug it is essentially
an exit drug from phungster some
pharmaceuticals and well you might
decrease the pain medication you might
reduce some of the other medications in
conjunction with that now compared to
opioids that 80% of opioids do not work
in chronic pain they're really good for
acute pain patients chronic pain they're
not as effective and a lot of people get
constipation up to 90% of patients get
constipation with opioids for pain
they're also highly addictive and they
also can cause overdose in comparison so
Mistel canvas has got good benefit in
this particular area and the
chemotherapy patients mostly there
there's some really good drugs out there
to prevent vomiting but when these
patients experience a metallic like
tongue nothing else works for none of
the other standard nausea drugs tend to
be very effective cannabis helps that
low-level norcia these patients they
feel when they're undergoing
chemotherapy in terms of MS patients
they get relief from spasm pain and they
can sleep better at night time now since
the January 2017 study there was a May
2017 study in it published in a New
England Medical Journal on refractory
epilepsy and cannabis and they studied
some drove AIDS patients that had
drug-resistant epilepsy that nothing
else worked for and they found up to 40%
of them with seizure free or greatly
reduce seizures using medicinal cannabis
of that is the fourth condition added to
the list of drugs the medical cannabis
can benefit there's many more under
investigation these are some of them
PTSD is wildly
cannabis is widely used the PTSD in
countries such as Israel Canada and the
u.s. in Israel and Canada the government
actually pay the war veterans to receive
medical cannabis because they know it
helps them and still requires a lot more
research and a godsend clinical trial
there's quite a bit of exciting research
going on anti-cancer effects of cannabis
and also anibus and chemotherapy in
conjunction to achieve better patient
outcomes now one the conditions I think
it is really exciting that has been
investigated currently is Alzheimer's
our outside this is a massive condition
that it's estimated one in ten patients
above the age of 65 will experience out
songs or dementia at some stage in a
lifetime and in pharmaceutical terms we
don't have many drugs to benefit these
patients we've got a arsenal drugs that
no cure is only for Alzheimer's and very
few drugs short of tranquilizing these
patients to make life easy to their
carers now if it has been from low-level
study and and some anecdotal research
that showing medical cannabis and may be
a benefit in these patients so I'd like
to see a lot more research in these
areas like any drug cannabis has drug
interactions there's four main areas at
this stage there's no major
contraindications I say
currently because it is a developing
science and there may be something that
comes up down the track
cannabis affects blood thinners like
warfarin so whilst it isn't a no-no to
take cannabis were you taking blood
thinners you may need to check the
levels more frequently canvas is
metabolized by cytochrome p450s or
anything else metabolized by this route
might need consideration chemicals so
inclusive
main cause drowsiness and lower blood
pressure so any other medications
effective affecting these might need to
be monitored pharmacokinetics is a
really interesting area now what my
siblings studied has been smoked
cannabis and the chemical ingredient EHD
so there's a lot more work going on this
area and now
what we know so far is smoking cannabis
isn't a very good delivery method
medically oral tends to be much better
when you smoke cannabis yet massive
amounts almost instantly and most of
that's eliminated within a short period
of time within a couple of hours may be
any body in trace amounts for up to a
couple weeks afterwards but in medical
terms you only get an effective dose
within two hours of the chronic
long-term patients they might need
all-day relief so oral is a far more
effective method to give medicine
cannabis and the stomach as a huge first
passed effect from their asset and there
is little by availability but it will
last longer sublingually is a great
method to give medicinal cannabis is
absorbed through the oral mucosa and
you're avoiding the first class effect
from the stomach get high
bioavailability actually we also get
goodbye availability without the psycho
activity of THC but commercially Rachel
administration isn't that popular I
think you're gonna see a lot more
topical best products in the future and
the molecular weight of THC is less than
400 so it is coming by the skin and
there's a lot of sea beauty food
receptors in the skin and so it does
achieve good medicinal benefits this
chart here and accurately shows the
difference between smoking cannabis
which as I said is not a good delivery
method medically and that is because it
only works for about an hour you achieve
to hire a dose of THC and quite often
you get psycho activity especially in
the first half an hour or so which is an
ideal for patients who are taking
cannabis medically their objective in
treatment is to get help rather than
high so when you take it orally in the
blue line it takes about a hour before
it clicks in you can make this a bit
faster by taking it sublingually when
it's absorbed through the oral mucosa
but you get good long low levels over a
24-hour period like a blood pressure
tablet or an antibiotic where the idea
is to have a
long blog Berg still getting a clinical
dosage are you getting good medical
benefits over a 24-hour period and then
you might take another dose each day to
maintain that curve and maintain the
benefits medically so in summary I don't
consider smoking to be a very good
delivery method orally is far better
so in those forms medically moving
forward I don't think you'll see as much
flour or bad smoked cannabis and in the
throat anyway there's probably only
about 10% of people who actually smoked
so they prefer other dosage forms like
sublingual tablets capsules you can see
oil sprays tinctures and left foam as
reasons poultries now here's a neat bit
of technology coming out of Israel it's
a slightly enhance the X Y Q P there's a
great video on YouTube
it's the inhaler being developed for
cannabis that connects up to a
smartphone and that way the doctor can
monitor the patient's dosage and the
patient can also have a record of what
cannabis they're using when and to what
effect and it's a great piece of
technology and I think you'll see a lot
more of it not only in cannabis users
but also other areas like asthmatic
patients etc this Canadian grow room and
medically cannabis needs to be grown the
same from batch to batch that way
patients get the same medication every
single time and it is really really
important because chronically ill
patients need to have consistent levels
of THC and CBD and by growing it indoors
you're controlling the season so the
plants get the same amount of sunlight
we're on official light in this case
water nutrients airflow pH et cetera
and you're also preventing pesticides
and it's that's important because since
pesticides introduced to the plant they
might be concentrated when you
concentrate the oil so it's important to
grow them this way also by growing this
way means they get to six crop turns
a year they can turn a clock in six to
eight weeks which economically is
important when they extract the the bud
or the flower these machinery like this
is co2 extraction equipment they may
need to further clean it up using
ethanol extraction I'm the jar on the
left hand thumb yellow mark in that the
the rule cameras that comes out of the
extraction they may further clean it up
and get rid of the waxes and the
chlorophyll and from there the jar on
the right is the good stuff at the end
which they will formulate and medicate
to the patient in standardized dosage
terms now I consider cannabis to be a
pharmaceutical disrupter for some
patients it offers benefit where there's
no other treatment options it can help
quite a number of patients and there's
some really exciting stuff being
developed I think gonna see a lot more
of it in in the future some of this
research comes online and it's a really
as I say exciting area of medicine that
I'm really enjoying looking at and
traveling the world with so thank you
very much for listening to me and talk
about medical cannabis I look forward to
answering any of your questions thank
you thank you Paul for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for so let's get started with
our first question
our first question asked can cannabis
cure cancer I hope so
there's a lot of research taking place
at the moment and one of the Israeli
scientists I know is doing a lot of work
in this area he summarized it to me that
it is a very difficult thing to quantify
because if hundred different types of
cancer all innovating different diseases
so he's testing every single type of
cannabis on every single type of
character and trying to get some answers
there now I often look how many strains
well how many types of cancer do you
hope to secure and he said well
realistically he's looking at four types
of cancer of the hundreds of types of
cancer that he'll hopefully be able to
cure I know he's done some preclinical
work he's done some work on rats totally
restarting human trials and there's a
number of other researchers around the
world doing doing work as well as I
mentioned there's some really great work
taking place in my hometown on cannabis
and chemotherapy they're looking at
pancreatic cancer models we just got a
very low survival rate and and there's
been some really good anecdotal cases
they're basing their research on so
hopefully that they will get some
answers there and people will get and
benefit excellent thank you and our next
question asks what strains are best for
pain hi I'm not a big fan of strains I
think in terms of pain you're gonna see
more THC and CBD levels moving forward a
lot of australians are purely marketing
where they've done a bit of work and
research and even those strains that are
called the same they contain varying
amounts of THC and CBD food typically
the best for pain creates you need to
treat all the symptoms as I said to you
if a patient's experiencing nausea you
might need to include loads of more THC
but typically what we're seeing for the
most common patients they're getting a
high CBD forma with small amounts of THC
and if you need more nausea control you
might need a higher amount of THC like a
one to one level
that's and some great farmers out there
with all with different amounts of THC
and CBD rather than strains excellent
thank you
if there are no more questions I'd like
to once again a thank Paul mayor for his
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through June of 2018 you will receive an
email from live roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live events that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you here again soon at lab roots